she's one of the most talked-about women
in Pakistan
Asya Bibi pictured here shortly after
her conviction in 2010 the Christian
mother of five was sentenced to death
for alleged remarks about Islam during a
round with fellow farmworkers that
refused to share their glass of water
with a non-muslim now free she lives in
hiding no longer on death row but still
in constant fear for her life and this
is why hardline Islamists calling for
her to be hanged
her acquittal in October last year
triggered days of nationwide
demonstrations in every corner of the
country the Sons of Islam have voiced
opposition to the Supreme Court verdict
by going on to the streets what kind of
a verdict is this from the supreme court
of an islamic republic which is
troubling muslims but satisfying
infidels demonstrations were a new
cooled off when the government agreed to
bar BB from leaving the country
pending today's verdict but this is a
case already linked to the killings of
at least two people the Governor of
Punjab province Samantha's iya seen here
on the right was assassinated by his
bodyguard in 2011 after speaking in
bebés defense later the same year
Federal Minister for minorities Shabazz
batty was killed after calling for her
release today's verdicts likely to do
little to appease those who will settle
for nothing less than having Asya bb's
death sentence reinstated
Oh DWS chamois Oh shams is following
this story from our Asia desk and he
joins us now show me up here BB has
already been acquitted what are the
chances that the court will now allow
that acquittal to be challenged on
appeal well I think it is highly likely
that Pakistan top coat will dismiss the
appeal against hacia babies last year
acquittal it the appeal by our hardline
Islamist was accepted by the court to
make sure that all legal requirements
are fulfilled and I think Prime Minister
Imran Khan's government also wanted to
buy some time to make some political
adjustments so I believe that Pakistan's
top court the Supreme Court will dismiss
the appeal now B B's acquittal last
October sparked violent protests what's
the mood in anticipation of today's
hearing well the Islamist auricular back
party this Lammas party has warned the
judges not to give what they call
judicial relief to be be hundreds of
Islamist supporters took to the streets
to protest B B's acquittal in October
last year but at the moment most of the
leaders and the cutter is incarcerated
so that is why I do not think they will
be able to create many problems in the
court or the government this time around
what does this case tell us shamil about
the way Pakistan interprets the
country's blasphemy laws well BB's
tragic ordeal reminds us that the issue
of blasphemy remains extremely extremely
sensitive in Pakistan right rights
groups criticize the blasphemy laws that
they say are used to mistreat religious
minorities in the country but I do not
think that any government in Pakistan
can repeal or amend the blasphemy laws
as any such goof could unleash you
violent protests from Islamists and I
also think that the common people he
would not accept that so it is a
sensitive issue but as I said earlier it
is very likely that the Supreme Court
will dismiss the review petition that
will pave the way for B B's departure
from Pakistan she could be out of the
country likely today show me oh thank
you very much for your analysis DW scam
use charms there from our Asia desk
thanks very much for having me on the
show
you